CATASTROPHES IN AMERICAN FOREIG
POLICY HISTORY.
ARI FLEISCHER SOUTH MALL DIDN'T
JUST TOOK A TRIP, HE WAS ONE OF
THE TWO PEOPLE AND AUTHORIZED T
GO INTO AFGHANISTAN YESTERDAY
WITH REPUBLICAN REPRESENTATIVE
MEYER.
SETH MOULTON, THAT HIGH PROFILE
NAME IS SAYING THERE IS NO WAY
WERE GOING TO GET EVERYBODY OUT
WE SIMPLY WILL LEAVE AMERICANS
BEHIND.
THERE IS NOT JUST A LITTLE BIT
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, ITS A WHILE.
>> THERE IS A LOT.
ADDING TO THAT LIST, YOUR RIGHT
TO MENTION SETH MOULTON.
ALSO ADAM SCHIFF, HE IS SAYING
IT'S UNLIKELY, ADAM SMITH ALSO
DEMOCRAT SAYS IT'S VERY UNLIKELY
.
KEVIN McCARTHY, L POSSIBLE WAY
BRAD JERMAN, A PRESENT
SAYING YOU'RE NOT QUITE GET
EVERYBODY OUT AND THIS IS JUST
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE ACKNOWLEDGING
REALITY.
ON FRIDAY, HE LOOKED INTO THE
CAMERA IN MADE THE COMMITMENT
QUOTE WE WILL GET YOU HOME TO
AMERICA.
HE WENT EVEN FURTHER AND SAID
QUOTE, WE ARE MAKING THE SAME
COMMITMENT TOO.
THAT WAS FRIDAY HE'LL BE OUT
THIS WEEK IN THAT COMMITMENT HA
GONE BY THE WAYSIDE.
THERE IS NO TRANSPARENCY HERE I
THE MEANTIME AS YOU WATCH THE
PENTAGON RETHINK, THEY HAVE A
DETAILED PERCENTAGE LIST OF THE
MEMBERS OF OUR MILITARY WHO ARE
VACCINATED POINT BY POINT,
BRANCH BY BRANCH, BUT THEY CAN
STILL NOT TELL US THE NUMBER OF
AMERICANS CAUGHT IN AFGHANISTAN.
IT IS AS STUNNING COMMUNICATION
CATASTROPHE ALL THE WAY ACROSS
FROM THE PENTAGON COME INTO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT RIGHT ON DOWN
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I WANT TO DRILL DOWN ON THAT
A BIT BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE LEAVE
THE COUNTRY THEY HAVE TO FLASH
THEIR PASSPORTS.
HOW IN THE WORLD CAN WE NOT KNO
WHICH AMERICANS ARE OVER THERE
IN AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S A TOURIST
DESTINATION IN THE PANDEMIC AND
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO SNEAK TO
GET THEIR.
>> WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF DISHES
DIFFERENT ISSUES GOING ON.
NUMBER ONE, YOU WOULD THINK IN
THE MONTHS LEADING UP TO THIS
WITHDRAWAL SINCE THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED IT IN APRIL, THAT WE
WOULD HAVE STARTED PULLING THOS
TOGETHER AND GETTING THOSE.
ONE THING WE RELY ON IS THE SAFE
, THE SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE
ARE SUPPOSED TO REGISTER WITH
THE U.S. EMBASSY SO THEY KNOW
THEY ARE THERE.
SO YOU'VE GOT ONE PROBLEM IN
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE.
IN THE NEXT WE WILL SEE WHAT
SECRETARY BLINKEN SAYS IN THE
NEXT HOUR IS IF THEY CAN GET
THAT NUMBER TO US.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE HAVE HAD TO EVACUATE
AMERICANS OUT OF A CRISIS.
LAST YEAR, DURING COVID, WHEN
THE WORLD SHUTDOWN IN COMMERCIA
AIRLINERS SHUT DOWN, MIKE POMPE
IN HIS STATE DEPARTMENT, WE HAD
TO EVACUATE IN REPATRIATE ALMOS
100,000 AMERICANS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD.
THIS IS A HUGE LOGISTICAL FEET,
SO IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT CAN DO THIS,
THEY ARE THE CAPABILITIES, BUT
THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE RIGHT
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP IN PLACE.
SECRETARY POMPEO EMPOWERED OUR
UNDERSECRETARY WHO IS
ESSENTIALLY THE FUEL OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO GET THIS
DONE IN HE PUT PEOPLE DIRECTLY
REPORTING TO HIM WHO WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR GETTING THE
100,000 AMERICANS HOME.
WHY HAS SECRETARY BLINKEN STILL
NOT DONE THAT.
WHERE IS THE POINT OF FAILURE A
THE STATE DEPARTMENT?
IS ANYONE IN THIS ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS DEBACLE?
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
FIRE ANYBODY.
>> I HOPE IF SECRETARY BLINKEN
STARTS TO TAKE QUESTIONS, THAT
THEY ARE TOUGHER ON HIM THAN
THEY DID IN THAT PREVIOUS
PENTAGON BRIEFING THAT WE GOT O
LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS ON THE
SAME THING IN WE HAVE GIVEN ALL
OF THOSE DETAILS.
GENERAL GRIFFIN WAS TRYING FOR
FOX NEWS, OTHERS IN THE ROOM
WERE TRYING, BUT THEY SIMPLY,
THEIR GOAL TODAY WAS SEEN WITH
MAJOR GENERAL, JUST DON'T MAKE
ANY HEADLINES.
JUST YOU KNOW, KEEP THE LINE
TIGHT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S A VERY MILITARY THING TO D
RIGHT NOW.
I WANT TO GET TO THIS BEFORE I
COME TO YOU, WE HAVE TWO
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN ON LAST
HOUR, ONE WAS THE FIRST ELECTED
TO CONGRESS FROM THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
AND ALSO, THE CHAIRMAN THE
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS MIKE McCALL OF
TEXAS.
HERE THEY ARE NOW.
>> NOW WITH THE PRESIDENT
DECIDING THAT IS THE DATE FOR
THE MILITARY TO GET COMPLETELY
OUT GREAT WHEN I SAY THERE'S
GOING TO BE BLOOD ON HIS HANDS,
PEOPLE WILL DIE IS A RESULT OF
THIS DECISION.
>> WE ARE ON THE CUSP OF HAVING
THE BIGGEST MASS HOSTAGE
SITUATION IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE 1979 IN
TEHRAN LOOK LIKE A SLEEPOVER.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS LEFT BEHIND THAT
THE TALIBAN WILL THEN HAVE FOR
LEVERAGE WHEN THEY WANT
INTERNATIONAL RECOGNITION, THEY
WANT MONEY, THEY WANT ECONOMIC
ASSISTANCE IN THEY'VE GOT A GUN
TO THE HEAD OF AMERICAN CITIZEN
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN LEFT THEM.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS TOO,
ARI ABOUT CONGRESSMAN WALZ, HE
DID SOME TIME IS AN ELITE BERET
SPECIAL FORCES OFFICER IN
AFGHANISTAN, SO HE KNOWS THE LA
OF THE LAND.
HE KNOWS THE TALIBAN.
YOUR REACTION TO SOME OF WHAT
YOU JUST HEARD?
[INAUDIBLE]
>> WE ARE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES WITH ARI FLEISCHER'S
MICROPHONE.
>> CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW?
>> GO AHEAD.
B2 AND WANTED TO GET YOUR
REACTION.
YOUR WORDS ARE TOO IMPORTANT TO
SKIP SO WE CAN'T DO YOU AGAIN.
WE WANT TO HEAR YOUR REACTION.
>> WHAT I WAS SAYING IS I HAVE
HEARD CRITICISM OF PRESIDENT
OFTEN IN MY LIFE, BUT WHAT IS S
DIFFERENT NOW IS WHEN YOU LISTE
TO THE TOME OF THEIR VOICE,
WHETHER IT'S A DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN, ESPECIALLY A VETERAN
, THEY ARE SO SCARED OF
THINGS THEY CAN GO WRONG BECAUS
THIS IS SO PERILOUS.
JOE BIDEN, HIS JUDGMENT IN THE
ACCURACY OF HIS WORDS.
HERE IS HIS HEARERS.
IS A PROBLEM.
LAST WEEK HE BECAME BEFORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE INSTEAD
AMERICANS WERE NOT HAVING
DIFFICULTY GETTING TO THE
AIRPORT WHEN OF COURSE THEY WERE
.
HE SAID THERE'S NO AL QAEDA IN
AFGHANISTAN ONE OF COURSE THERE
IS.
HE SAID HE WASN'T BEING
CRITICIZED BY FOREIGN LEADERS
WHEN HE WAS.
AND NOW THIS WEEK HE SAYS WERE
ON TRACK TO GET EVERYBODY OUT.
AFTER HAVING SAID THAT ALL
AMERICANS WILL BE BROUGHT OUT
AND ALL THE AFGHANS THAT WANT T
BE BROUGHT OUT TOO.
CAN WE RELY ON JOE BIDEN WHEN H
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON?
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE HAVE THE EDG
TO THEM, THIS IS WHY IT IS SO
PERILOUS BECAUSE IT APPEARS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS NOT IN CONNECTION WITH PEOPL
ON THE GROUND IS JUST SPEAKING
IN WEARING ROSE-COLORED GLASSES
IN A TIME WHEN WE NEED REALISM.
YOU TURN ON THE TV AND YOU
REALIZE HOW PERILOUS IT IS FOR
THE PEOPLE TRYING TO GET TO THE
AIRPORT.
>> SOME OF WHAT THEY'VE TOLD US
ARI, AND THIS STARTED WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN THEN SPREAD TO THE
PENTAGON IN THEN JEN PSAKI, AND
IT'S THESE WORDS, FOR EVERY
AMERICAN WHO WANTS TO COME HOME
WE WILL GET YOU HOME.
IF YOU CAN'T GET TO THAT AIRPORT
, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
READ A WOMAN OR A MAN'S HEART,
YOU CAN'T EVEN GET THEM TO THE
AIRPORT.
IT SO DISINGENUOUS, HE'S TALKIN
TO US AS THOUGH WE'RE STUPID.
AT LEAST WERE IN A SAFE SPACE,
RIGHT?
WE ARE IN A STUDIO SOMEWHERE,
THESE ARE HEARING THE SAME
DISINGENUOUS WORDS, AND IT MUST
FEEL LIKE HATE TO THEM.
>> AND WE ARE FOCUSED ON,
EVERYTHING YOU SAID IS VALID.
BUT IT'S NOT AS IF EVERYBODY IS
JUST IN THE ONE PLACE WHERE
THEY'RE HAPPENS TO BE AN AIRPORT
.
WHEN JEN PSAKI YESTERDAY WAS
SAYING THIS WAS GOING TO BE THE
LARGEST EVACUATION IN OUR
HISTORY, THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN THE LARGEST EVACUATION OF
PEOPLE IN OUR HISTORY.
THE ONLY REASON WE HAVE TO
EVACUATE PEOPLE IS BECAUSE WE
ABANDONED THEM.
THE PROPER WAY TO DO IT IS FOR
PEOPLE TO GET COMMERCIAL FLIGHT
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
IN THERE'D BE NOBODY LEFT TO
EVACUATE.
IT SHOULD BE THE SMALLEST
EVACUATION IN HISTORY IF IT WAS
DONE WHILE.
IT'S ONLY GOING TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT EVACUATION BECAUSE
IT WAS DONE SO POORLY.
>> DID YOU SEE THE VIDEO OF THE
PEOPLE STANDING OUTSIDE THE
GATES OF THE AIRPORT?
IT IS SO HARD TO WATCH.
THAT IS PURE SEWAGE THAT PEOPLE
ARE STANDING IN PART IT'S A SHO
JUST BEFORE THIS ONE.
THEY ARE STANDING IN SEWAGE.
OR DOING WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
GET AN.
I HAD A FORMER ARMY RANGER
INTERPRETER ON WITH ME JUST A
FEW MINUTES BEFORE "OUTNUMBERED
STARTED.
HE'S WORRIED SO MUCH ABOUT HIS
FAMILY.
HE GOT OUT, BUT HE'S GOT TO GET
THEM OUT NOW.
CAN YOU IMAGINE STANDING IN THA
TRYING TO GET OUT?
YOU'RE GETTING SICK JUST TRYING
TO SAVE YOUR LIFE BECAUSE LORD
KNOWS WHAT'S IN THAT WATER.
>> THIS IS TRAGEDY UPON TRAGEDY.
I THINK THE WORST PART FOR ME I
THE NOTION THAT THIS WAS IN SOM
WAY PREVENTABLE.
THE NOTION THAT IF THERE WAS
SOME MODICUM OF ACTUAL
LEADERSHIP FROM OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, ACTUAL
TRANSPARENCY, IF THERE WAS AN
ABILITY TO LISTEN TO THE
MULTITUDES OF PLANS SUBMITTED T
HIM ACROSS THE GOVERNMENT BY
VETERANS, BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, BY THE DEPARTMENT O
DEFENSE, AND MORE, THAT THERE
WOULD BE A MORE SEAMLESS
TRANSITION, A BETTER EXTRACTION
THAN THE ABSOLUTE SURRENDER AND
ABANDONMENT WE'VE SEEN UP UNTIL
NOW.
I DO LIKE TO HEAR MORE FROM
MORGAN ON THIS.
YOU TOUCHED ON SUCH A VALUABLE
POINT THAT IS IN THE REFUSAL TO
DELEGATE ANY TYPE OF
RESPONSIBILITY OR POWER, THAT I
WHY EVERYTHING IS BENCHING AT
THE TOP.
WE ARE HEARING FROM ALL ASPECTS
OUT THE GOVERNMENT IN AGAIN WIT
ORDINARY AMERICANS SEEING WE
HAVE A CHARTERED FLIGHT, WE HAV
EVERYTHING AVAILABLE, BUT WERE
MISSING A PERMIT TO LAND FOR
EXAMPLE.
WE'RE HEARING FROM CONGRESSMAN
GALLAGHER, WHY DO WE KEEP
SURRENDERING OUR POWER TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
WE HAVE MORE POWER, LET'S PASS
LEGISLATION IN GET THESE
AMERICANS AND ALLIES AND HOME.
WHAT IS YOUR INSIGHT THAT WE'RE
SEEN, THE BUNCHING AT THE TOP I
AN ABSOLUTE LOSS OF LIFE?
QUICKIE JUST QUICKLY I THINK
WHENEVER YOU HAVE A LOTS OF
PEOPLE IN CHARGE, YOU HAVE NO
ONE IN CHARGE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CONGRESS
WILL NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IS WHERE IS THE POINT OF
FAILURE AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT?
WHY WEREN'T THESE APPLICATIONS
BEING PROCESSED.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN APRIL AND
AUGUST?
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE CRUCIAL
QUESTION.
UNDER MIKE POMPEO, HE MADE TO
THE PEOPLE WERE APPOINTED TO
POSITIONS, THEY WERE IN CHARGE
AND THEY WERE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
TRUST MAY HAVE BEEN IN THE ROOM
WHEN HE'S HELD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
TO GET A HAVE ONE QUESTION.
IS SOMEONE LYING TO US ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE GROUND
AND WHO IS MAKING THE DECISIONS
TO DO SO.
IF THE PRESIDENT CAN HONESTLY
SAY IN MEAN THAT HE DOESN'T KNO
ABOUT THE DANGERS ON THE GROUND
OUTSIDE THAT AIRPORT IN HOW
DEADLY IT'S GOING TO BE WHEN OU
AMERICAN MILITARY PULLS OUT.
IF THEY ARE NOT TELLING HIM,
THAT IS ONE THING, BUT IF THEY
ARE NOT TELLING HIM SO THAT WE
AREN'T TOLD, THAT